I think also motherhood just puts life
into perspective and what's important to
you Khloe Kardashian is putting her
daughter first as she and ex Tristan
Thompson figure out how to co-parent
little true in the wake of Tristan's
latest alleged cheating scandal
despite their rocky relationship a
source tells ET quote Khloe and Tristan
may have their issues but Khloe will
never deny Tristan a chance to spend
time with his daughter I think you just
re-evaluate things like I don't want to
do that tonight and it's okay to say no
so I can spend time with my family
according to our source the 34 year old
reality star takes care of true the
majority of the time but there is no
formal custody agreement in place this
seems to be a matter of flexibility for
the good American creator our source
says Khloe's able to bring true or be
with her at work where Tristan can't
throughs parents called it quits when
news broke that Tristan allegedly
cheated with Jordan Woods Kylie Jenner's
former BFF Chloe initially called out
Jordan for breaking up her family before
backtracking and blaming Tristan 21-year
old Jordan denied Khloe's claims on
read.table talked with Jada
pinkett-smith I know I'm not the reason
that Tristan and Chloe are not together
I'm no homewrecker I would never try to
hurt someone's home especially someone
that I love and someone who has a
beautiful daughter Jordan admits she
messed up while partying at the NBA pros
home and according to our source if
Tristan was out or having parties
without Chloe she was hopeful he was
being respectful our source adds Chloe
took Tristan back previously because she
believed that after everything he'd make
the decision to put his family first but
knew she couldn't control him
it's really hard to regain trust you're
one stupid weekend
did you just demolish the relationship
chloe appears to address everything on
the upcoming season of Keeping Up with
the Kardashians but right now her focus
is on true our source claims that
Tristan feels horrible but the family
thinks that is only because he got
hot adding true is the only thing that
matters not Tristan's lies at one point
the 34 year old reality star was sharing
emotional and cryptic messages about
betrayal on social media I was like how
am I gonna get through this day
we're told Chloe is getting better day
by day as for whether she and Tristan
will ever reconcile their romance our
source says that's a no-go Chloe is very
big about I'm having the father of her
child staying in her life no matter how
bad things get but Chloe and Tristan
aren't getting back together and Chloe
knows she needs to move on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]